[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découverte alors allons-nous
[Musique]
comment
il est
misérables alors au samedi dans la
commune de Saint-Paul nous les dans la
forêt de sans souci et ben nous nous va
aller jusqu'au roi tamarin une note dans
l'allée et 50 minutes le retour quand
vous l'étiez coincé en France rien que
ça même moins dépenses avoir si l'on
retrouve mon moment rien que la même mot
qui a des danses derrière elle est là la
montagne ni un soleil à cross fait pipi
comme si la nature déconnait à la
paradis pour nous rester
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment il est
bien au même ça va bien
je travaille pour l'Office national des
forêts de la Réunion d'accord viens ici
on est dans la réserve biologique de
bois de nefles et je viens là ici en
fait à la fois pour surveiller vérifier
l'état du sentier suite au forte pluie
qui a eu après le cyclone Freddy voir
s'il y a besoin de faire intervenir nos
ouvriers pour permettre de réouvrir le
sentier permettre à tout le monde de
pouvoir profiter de la balade aller
jusqu'au roi des Tamarins il était moins
la passe dans la forêt là nous on en a
bon pépé de bois quel genre de bonne
guerre retrouver dans cette forêt là on
en a déjà un exemple bien marquant juste
derrière vous ok
là un bon vieux sujet là ici on est sur
un pied de bois maigre d'accord du coup
on est 1000 de la Réunion OK et ben on
peut le voir là ici par rapport déjà la
taille qui fait en termes de diamètre la
hauteur qu'il a pris et là on voit à
l'intérieur avec un petit coup de
lumière à l'intérieur on voit que il y a
déjà un bon espace ici et ça là c'est un
très bon indicatif pour dire que c'est
un pied de bois qui a certainement vu
passer quelques vides ok alors du coup
dis-moi est-ce que nous on a d'autres
pays de bois l'évier comme pieds de bois
là ça s'en est un annonciateur parce que
les plus vieux ils sont après ouais on
trouve là quand on continue le chemin
vous avez trouvé des gros pieds de temps
rouge qui sont pareils c'est difficile
de le dire mais je pense au moins dans
les 15200 ans d'accord et après vous
avez l'ancêtre le patriarche de la forêt
bien connu ici à la Réunion qui
s'appelle le roi de minutes
grosso modo
on a trouvé
alors Mégane mon monte au bout de 1h12
de marche noir arrive chez le fameux roi
tamarin ok
et les domaines vraiment la forêt bah
d'où son nom le roi tamarin les
magnifiques à ça alors il paraît que le
roi Tamara il y en a plus de 500 ans et
ben nous ça nous a fait il nous reste
sur le massif du Maïdo et nous va aller
découvrir comment il bataille comme
bonnes espèces exotiques envahissant et
ben nous on va aller par là
bonjour monsieur
oui effectivement là nous sur un
chantier de lutte contre la joie
d'Europe donc c'est une espèce
particulièrement invasive d'accord donc
qu'on nous retrouve donc pas mal donc
sur le secteur du McDo et donc là donc
c'est un chantier donc mise en place par
le département avec un encadrement de
l'ONF
et avec le soutien donc financier donc
de l'État notamment donc dans le cas du
plan de relance sur la biodiversité
c'est des des ouvriers donc qui a été
recrutés donc par le Département donc et
qui sont encadrés donc par l'ONF donc
avec un ensuite donc un volet donc suivi
socio-professionnel qui effectué par
l'aspel Eden pour que et
donc onef qui est à la fois donc défini
donc le programme d'action donc et
l'encadrement des équipes solaires mais
il propose d'aller voir Stéphane
merci Ciao
ça va bien merci
c'est un espèce les cinq plus répandu au
monde donc c'est une vraie peste les
étages et est-ce que nous connais
comment il arrive my Dolly pour la
Réunion l'histoire
du peut-être c'est des touristes sous
autre pied avec des grains avec les
baskets ou une histoire aussi dit que
Nana des gens là mène ça pour les les
bêtes les bœufs avant pour manger
toute l'année il a dit en fin de compte
toute l'année mais de d'année on a
énormément améliore une bonne lutte donc
nous pensons que nous on va pouvoir
faire le 55 ans de l'argent plus notre
forêt bois de couleur d'accord merci
bien à trouver
la lutte contre l'agent d'Europe et si
elle ouvre les découvre un passage de
restauration écologique allez
allons-nous
bonjour Laurent
tranquille les diamants
une restauration écologique
restauration écologique que ça veut dire
ça alors restauration écologique qui
veut dire que nous fait de la lutte
contre les espèces envahissantes et que
nous vieillons au boisé quand la
végétation naturelle il revient pas
assez facilement nous viend reboiser
avec des espèces indigènes est-ce que
l'important ce travail là ah oui les
fondamental parce que en fin de compte
si on fait pas cette hydro plantation là
c'est toujours les espèces exotiques qui
vont revenir tous les envahissent
toujours revenir et donc c'est un siècle
sans fin et même va étaler au fur et à
mesure sur les endroits que les
conseillers à côté donc les
fondamentales d'arriver à faire ce
travail de restauration écologique là
s'il devait préserver notre patrimoine
que ça ne peut retrouver de quel pays de
bois en particulier
retrouve trois végétations différentes
au fur et à mesure qu'on monte donc là
nous les donne à part si semi sec donc
les espèces va diap caractéristiques
c'est bois d'aranet
Bouddha bois de nef d'ailleurs d'un
quartier pas de bois neuf pas trop loin
donc c'est pour ça et donc ça c'est les
caractéristiques puis Lina elle
partenariat que nous l'a fait chez cette
opération là et puis particulier avec le
parc national et ne va plus au plan des
espèces protégées des espèces protégées
normalement on a pas le droit aux
planter comme ça il faut un autorisation
spéciale et dans le cas d'un projet qui
appelle le projet espèce que le partage
l'a fait il en avait cette autorisation
là donc n'a plus de planter du Tibo de
santé et du poivrier des hauts d'accord
ok
ben voilà l'emballage qu'elle est à le
cité vraiment gars et puis avec les
primordial la lutte contre les espèces
invasives et puis la restauration
écologique ça l'important ok la réunion
a gagné
et pour ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode de l'émission nous on sera du
côté de neuf et la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]